okay so we go
for the next game he's already gone e4
he's clearly very eager to
strike back um what should i do
what should i do
okay let's be really really boring
play the old berlin
d4 okay
wow e5 okay
uh i guess this is
not that bad a line not e4 i should go
a6
right
bishop c4 i can feel the tricks coming
but i don't know
for the moment i'm not too worried
will i aim for punishment or not knowing
myself i probably won't
because bishop e7 and then
just giving up d4 and castling seems
very reasonable
i might be just
a tiny bit worse but i don't think
i don't think it's anything real
and what's wrong with bishop g4 though
trying to keep uh trying to
to keep the pawn
yeah i don't see it
clearly it clearly has prepared us so
it's just not
he's not just missing this okay so he
sacrifices a pawn
i guess he has reasonable positional
compensation here
but i'm not impressed
not by any means maybe bishop d5
i do have queen d7 yeah this i just
castle
obviously
so it's it's a little bit dull but
i think if anybody's better here it's
probably me
[Music]
how to stay hydrated
take your bathroom breaks in between
games if you have to but
staying hydrated is number one
uh rook d1
looks really artificial
okay so i think what i'm going to do is
bishop g5
a trade would in general seem quite
desirable for me
and if he moves this bishop to h2
i think that is some kind of achievement
for me
maybe then i can go queen e7 followed by
rook a to e8
after he goes knight to d2
in general i'm just trying to put my
pieces on decent squares and
um and um
also trying to keep the extra pawn
obviously yeah i think queen
7 is pretty maybe 27 and then 92 rookie
8 is also not bad
intending then bishop d2 followed by 94
exchanging some pieces
i think that's not bad like the hand
the hand kind of wants queen seven
maybe the hand is wrong so i'm going
rook e8 just to keep an extra high
sorry rook 88 to keep an extra iron f7
when you your opponent's bishop is on d3
um
you always kind of want to keep an extra
eye on that square
so his idea just go knight f5
knight c4 looks uh really suspicious to
me
oh wait a sec knight f5 there is bishop
c7
then there is p5 though
knight b6 queen c7 queen f5 rookie five
knight d5 queen d6 queen of three
and he's okay okay so we go we got
knight e4
and if 95 i guess i i take it and then i
go back
i'm not thrilled but it's okay
i gotta play faster at some point
obviously
i guess he has reasonable compensation
here but
still believe i'm slightly better
95 was a good move though
i think he's gonna go queen of three
yeah queen d5
was an option but i don't think it was
uh
it was too great okay origin 7 first
maybe
try to double the rooks um
in life for a better thing to do
obviously there's no threat against
d4 since the queen will protect
protect the pawn via
this this is a bit surprising
yeah he does get his pawn back but
i think i have some initiative now
he loses the bishop pair and
my pawn on d4 now that it's supported by
c5 is
suddenly quite strong so the only
question here is
whether you can start running the a pawn
uh you can take on c5 but i'm not
worried i took on g3 i'll take another
two rookie two cons
and i'm doing well now queen f5 rookie
two is a serious threat
i guess he has to go
i guess he has to go queen d3 yeah
so he does if i take rookie two
a4 b2 a5 book e2
not convinced by that okay so we got f6
and
still intending rookie 2. okay
here we go rook d2
the other one comes to e2
yeah so he goes for this but this is a
much better queen trade because now i
have a passport as well
take and i run
c4 my pawn should be
unstoppable here i think okay gotta
protect the rook
yeah just let's just trade
rook a4 i just push and this is game
over
d2
okay gotta be tiny bit careful maybe
it takes rook d3 maybe there's no one
okay so e3 we go rook c7
rook a3 and that's it now i take an a7
and once again
there's a rook ending and i have two
connected past pawns that's gonna win in
the game
a little bit closer to uh promotion this
time
but you can sense a theme right